for some reason you don't have a TV to
hook up your PlayStation 4 to or you
don't have a lot of space to have it
laying around your living room one
option you do have is to buy [ __ ] ease
full HD monitor for the PlayStation 4 it
sits on top of the system and supports
1080p resolution so you can see all your
games and all their great fidelity this
thing cost $300 though some people got
it on Amazon recently for 15 regardless
will you pay for it let's take a look
and see what it does
lori's PlayStation 4 monitor cost $300
which is almost as much as the system
itself it's a hefty price to pay for a
monitor that isn't as portable as it
looks because it actually requires its
own external power supply however it
does integrate with the console
extremely well setup is easy simply set
the unit on top of the PlayStation 4
attach the two clamps that secure to the
system and connect the power and HDMI
cable thankfully for you included a
short HDMI cable to prevent unnecessary
clutter
you'll also find two headphone jacks on
the back of the monitor which may come
in handy but since every PlayStation 4
controller has its own headphone jack
you probably won't end up using these on
the monitor very often games look crisp
on Corey's monitor thanks to its high
pixel density at the default settings
the color tends to be a bit
oversaturated but this is easily fixable
if you dive into the monitor settings
menu though it's not going to make a
difference in every type of game the
monitor does have a slow response time
of 25 milliseconds well above the modern
standard for gaming grade monitors which
isn't a good thing if you're expecting
great audio from this monitor prepare to
be disappointed sound effects a music
exhibit at inequality you're far better
off using the headphone jack on your
controller at the end of the day
so would I pick up this monitor for $300
no way for 15 bucks sure but that was a
mistake on Amazon's part that's probably
why you all heard about this monitor in
the first place that's because it's just
an unremarkable piece of tech the screen
is okay but it has a really slow
response time the audio is not great and
it's also not portable it needs its own
DC adapter so it's really hard to
recommend this unless you absolutely
have no option when it comes to using
traditional monitors